[Música]
los colombianos elegirán este 13 de
marzo a los integrantes del senado de la
cámara de representantes crucial para la
gobernabilidad de quien llega a ser el
próximo presidente colombiano el
estallido social el aumento de la
violencia en las regiones muestra un
contexto distinto al que colombia tenía
hace cuatro años hay 934 candidatos para
los 108 escaños del senado de los cuales
cinco ya están garantizados para el
partido comunes surgido de la
desmovilización de las farc como parte
del acuerdo de paz que firmaron el
gobierno y la guerrilla 2016 además se
estrenarán las 16 curules de paz para
las víctimas y en el que también comunes
cuenta con cinco puestos los colombianos
van a elegir también a los candidatos
presidenciales de tres grandes
coaliciones de centro derecha e
izquierda y como podría estar confirmado
todo este senado nuevo pues saludamos
entonces a nuestro primer invitado del
día gracias por estar con nosotros en
france a 24 y quería preguntarle
entonces cómo podría estar conformado
este en nuevo el senado en colombia
la conformación va a presentar un cambio
sensible y el cambio va a estar
determinado por el hecho de que no va a
existir no va a brotar de este proceso
electoral una mayoría
clara va a haber
fraccionamiento de partidos pero no sólo
precisamente que ya existe sino
coaliciones no suficientemente
potentes
para hacer un cambio de la tendencia
nuestros 20 años en los últimos 20 años
ha habido competiciones en el congreso
hegemónica es de más del 65%
con la mayoría de más del 65% en esta
ocasión desde el punto vista el campo
digamos del centroderecha va a haber el
sobre 100 va a haber unos 40 senadores
mientras que por el lado de la izquierda
y del centroizquierda haber unos 38
ninguno de ellos asegura la mayoría
simple del 51 por ciento de manera que
este es el nuevo contexto que se va a
presentar a partir de esta elección la
ausencia de una mayoría neta primero de
todo todos los partidos son pequeñas
minorías todas sus minorías
estoy hablando incluso de coaliciones
ninguna coalición tiene garantizado de
antemano el 51 por ciento de eso es lo
nuevo va a haber un partido que quizás
sirva como dicen en algunos países en
francia por ejemplo partido bisagra que
sería el partido liberal donde con el
partido liberal chicos de pan el centro
de leche o si con el centroizquierda
con una mayoría pero precario una
mayoría que llegue por el 51
qué consecuencias trae pues dificultades
en la gobernabilidad
gobernabilidad es la posibilidad de
tomar decisiones y de que éstas se
implementen una veces grandes decisiones
son las leyes y para las leyes es
sustancial y determinante la presencia
de un congreso de manera que es
importantísimo para la gobernabilidad en
materia legislativa la articulación
entre ejecutivo y legislativo en esta
ocasión esa articulación va a presentar
dificultades por la ausencia de entrada
de una mayoría sólida alrededor del
gobierno de manera que yo tenemos la
obligación el reto para el gobierno
cualquiera sea el de poder de tener que
articular construir conformar mediante
consensos una mayoría suficiente para
las reformas que se reformas en el orden
social en el orden constitucional en el
orden económico y para eso necesita una
mayoría sólida cierto ahí es donde está
lo nuevo me parece a mí que quiero
destacar es la ausencia de una mayoría
sólida en el futuro congresos y han
funcionado como cámara ahora ricardo
permita presentarlo a nuestra audiencia
ricardo garcía abogado en la universidad
nacional de colombia politólogo del
instituto de estudios políticos de parís
ricardo ya con esta presentación que no
la hice antes por eso estoy haciendo
esta salvedad ahora para que la
audiencia sepa con qué estamos hablando
cómo llega a colombia a estas elecciones
llega a estas elecciones bajo dos
circunstancias
nueve mapas en primer precedido de un
gran ascenso en la protesta social
colombia fue el
escenario
de grandes protestas con presencia
acentuada de la juventud inconforme ese
es un elemento que precede a estas
elecciones
eso seguramente va a incidir en la
agenda pero también en la
orientación de los votantes en la medida
en que
el voto
digamos que más amistad va a disminuir
mientras importante o combinado está lo
que tuvieron o que van a tener
seguramente en las elecciones las
protestas de hace dos años esa es una
circunstancia y la otra circunstancia es
la disminución sustantiva en las
encuestas
el partido que hace cuatro años ganó ya
que ese es una circunstancia nueva que
va a descender en el favor popular el
partido que ganó hace cuatro años es
decir el que están gobernando
actualmente que muy seguramente puede
estar por fuera del escenario definitivo
para las elecciones presidenciales que
no es la de ahora si es pero que hay que
irlas observando en el panorama en
perspectiva va es posible que queremos
ser
en la batalla final ese sería un cambio
muy importante en los comportamientos y
en el sistema de partidos primera vez
ahí la posibilidad de un gobierno nacido
de uno de los partidos tradicionales sin
origen en los partidos tradicionales y
más bien originado en fuerzas
independientes e incluso originado en
una guerrilla como fue la medición es
claro no es que vaya a quedar pero hay
posibilidades cierto entonces eso es un
cambio importante
riccardo hablemos entonces de uno de los
cambios más importantes estas 16 curules
de paz cuál sería su peso en el congreso
es importante la presencia de estas
nuevas curules de paz son 16 sirio
decena de
circunscripciones que han sido escenario
de violencias entonces van dirigidas a
que haya representación de las víctimas
su importancia deriva de allí de la
posibilidad de que víctimas de zonas
azotadas por la violencia
tengan presencia en el escenario por
excelencia de la representación como es
el congreso no va a ser en las dos
cámaras va a ser solamente en lo que
podríamos llegar en el lenguaje esta
opción o la cámara baja se o la cámara
simplemente es alguien no en el senado
ha tenido inconvenientes hay que decirlo
la tiene que superar inconvenientes
muchos de ellos han tenido que renunciar
los candidatos si llevamos eso ha habido
cuestionamientos y han tenido que
renunciar por otras dificultades en los
requisitos para inscribirse pero una vez
pase la elección creo yo que va a
constituir su número de 16 va a
constituir un peso importante ahora no
todos
tener la misma condición de víctimas
allí sean digamos infiltrados y si
quiere o en su presencia personas que no
necesariamente son víctimas pero aún así
creo que va a ser una franja muy
importante en la cámara de
representantes no así en el senado y va
a servir para que para darle fuerza a mi
querido periodista una cosa muy
importante que es finalizar la
aplicación del acuerdo de paz y en ese
acuerdo de paz está el tema de tierras y
de víctimas así que ahí tienes la
oportunidad para tener influencia en
materializar todo aquello que falta por
cumplir en el acuerdo de paz pues
ricardo gracias por su tiempo por
analizar un poco entonces lo que se nos
viene en estas elecciones
parlamentarias en colombia me hubiera
encantado estar con usted un poco paz
pero lamentablemente el tiempo se nos
agota gracias ricard un gran abrazo
gracias a todos ustedes un abrazo